that the best you've got
extraordinary reports coming out of the
Soviet Union
tales of a bee with powers and abilities
far beyond those of mortal men as I said
mr. president of course I understand
your concern but I assure you the Luthor
company has this under control
I don't blame those among you that fear
me or you've been taught to fear all
your lives
this is a world where the strong rule
and you are the strongest all of us it
is only a matter of time very little
time until all of Western Europe is
absorbed is taken by the Soviet Superman
look alive lanterns we've got it coming
I'm honored to have you here invested
there call me Diana and what shall I
call you Superman
you think you're going to stop me
battling
what now
now I saved the world welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my Superman red Sun trailer breakdown
most of you are at least vaguely
familiar with the story if you never
read it it's a 2003 else world story by
Mark Millar who just had this idea as a
kid what would have happened if
Superman's pod would have landed in the
Soviet Union back in the 1950s during
Cold War Soviet Union instead of landing
in Kansas it's a great story so it was
only a matter of time before they
adapted it into an animated movie and
from the look of the trailer they're
being pretty authentic to the plot of
the original comic book so we'll just
break this down and explain what's going
on with the story if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're doing a new round
of that flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite DC Elseworlds story
on the video there's been a lot of jokes
recently that Warner Brothers doesn't
know what to do with the Superman
character this is a fantastic Superman
story even though I don't know that I
would want to see this live-action
before seeing other mainstream main
Universe Superman movies but the story
picks up in the 1950s soviet union in
the depths of the Cold War Stalin is
still in control of the Communist Party
but Stalin died in 1953 so Stalin does
wind up dying during the course of the
events of this story you initially start
the story thinking it's gonna be a
straight-up retelling of the original
Superman origin story but it's way
twistier than that there's a whole bunch
of familiar stuff you see in here
obviously you see Green Lantern's you
see a Russian version of Batman who's
coming for him Dark Knight Returns style
and you see a version of Wonder Woman
that's looking like she's wearing a
Russian version of her Wonder Woman
costume it is a bit of a twist on the
cold arms race during the 50s and the
60s but there's a big time-travel plot
that happens during the story too so it
gets way way crazier than you would
expect but the Soviet Union just reveals
to the world that they have the Superman
so everyone starts freaking out and that
begins the cold war race Jimmy Olsen is
a CIA agent that recruits Lex Luthor
who's a scientist working at STAR Labs
to destroy Superman as you've seen the
trailer what he does is he causes
Sputnik to to crash into metropolis so
Superman diverts the satellites saving
everyone
but Lex Luthor uses that as an
opportunity to collect some genetic
material from Superman and create a
clone that he named Superman
- this whole subplot was Stalin's
illegitimate child trying to seize power
and get rid of Stalin the communist
party starts to order Superman to do
more dangerous and dangerous things
slowly spreading communism around the
rest of the world in the Warsaw Pact he
runs into his childhood friend a Russian
version of Lana Lang that inspires him
to do good
eventually Lex Luthor and the u.s. send
the Superman clone after Russians
Superman they engage in battle and it
causes an accidental nuclear missile
attack on Great Britain the clone
sacrifices himself and then Lex Luthor
winds up killing his research staff at
STAR Labs founds Luthor Corp and
dedicates the rest of his life to
destroying Superman so all the main
players in the Superman Canon have a lot
of the same relationships it just
everything goes down in a very very
different way they jump forward in time
to the 1970s and because of the
influence of this Russian Superman
communism has spread everywhere the
Soviet Union is prospering the u.s. is
on the verge of collapse
Lex Luthor starts working with a version
of Brainiac to shrink the Soviet Union
and get rid of Superman it doesn't wind
up working Lex Luthor's next plan is to
use the Russian version of Batman that
you see fighting Superman in the trailer
that Batman winds up killing himself to
avoid being turned into a robot
quote-unquote of the state they
developed this new technique within the
Soviet Union to turn people into
quote-unquote Superman robots that just
obey blindly things begin to escalate
remember this is sort of a metaphor for
the Cold War and the escalation between
the US and the Soviet Union in real life
eventually Lex Luthor's fourth plan is
to use the new Green Lantern Corps that
he finds in this version of events
Abin SURS Green Lantern ship crashes in
Roswell New Mexico and he's found by Lex
Luthor in the government eventually Lex
Luthor becomes President of the United
States marries Lois Lane she becomes
Lois Luthor then he helps found a Green
Lantern Corps that essentially becomes
the Marine Corps of the United States so
it's a bunch of Marines that become
Green Lantern's Soviet Superman launches
an attack on the eastern coast of the
United States Lex Luthor sends his Green
Lantern Corps marines after
there's even a subplot with Wonder Woman
in the movie where she's actually trying
to ingratiate herself with Superman she
starts to fall in love with him but
there's this weird thing where this
version of Superman doesn't what have
anything to do with her not that he
doesn't like her it just that he doesn't
pay attention to her or give her any of
the consideration that she wants as the
story follows the characters through the
decades eventually one of Lex Luthor's
plots involves capturing Wonder Woman
and using her to blackmail Superman
Superman is able to save her they're
able to defeat Lex Luthor's plan but she
finds during the course of their
adventure that Superman just doesn't
really care about her that much so
eventually she becomes kind of
embittered and winds up going off to
live on Themis Kara there very few
stories where Wonder Woman actually
winds up getting together with a version
of Superman speaking of which were in
the middle of crisis on Infinite Earths
on the CW with the live-action DC TV
shows they're doing Brandon brow as
Kingdom Come Superman the older version
of his Superman from Superman Returns
who's also kind of an older version of
Christopher Reeve Superman within the
Kingdom Come comic book story eventually
after the death of Lois Lane many many
years in the future
Wonder Woman because she's one of the
few people the Superman could be with
because they both live so long
eventually do become a couple and have a
child together but you're just kind of
left to wonder what that child's going
to be the child of Superman and Wonder
Woman even just talking about it a
little bit I'm like wow why don't they
just do Kingdom Come is an animated
movie next that would be badass the
version of Kingdom comes Superman that
they've been doing during crisis on
Infinite Earths it's sort of an amalgam
of a couple of different versions of
Superman so it's not straight up right
out of kingdom come and during DC TV
crisis on Infinite Earths they didn't
really go deeper onto what's going on
with the other Justice League characters
within the world of that Kingdom Come
Superman it's actually one of the least
insane things I've ever heard
first stay in face litter and you won't
do it alone
Braniac winds up turning into a much
bigger villain and eventually killing
Superman
so without Superman the Soviet Union
sort of falls into disarray eventually
Lex Luthor becomes this benevolent
person in the history of the United
States leads humanity to all these
future accomplishments the story jumps
forward billions of years later in the
future earth is being torn apart by
tidal stresses from the Sun which has
become a red giant
Lex Luthor's distant descendant jor-el
sends his infant son kal-el rocketing
back into the past in the very end of
the story is basically Superman's pod
landing in the Ukraine in 1938 and it
becomes as big predestination paradox so
the story of Superman Reds son isn't
just a twist on the Superman origins
story it's also a big time travel story
as well and it's all about Superman
realizing that he's not really meant to
meddle in human affairs
the other big twist being that that
version of Superman who came from the
future technically is actually the
distant descendant of Lex Luthor in Lois
Lane the very person who dedicated his
life to destroying him throughout his
lifetime in the past they don't list a
release date for when this movie is
actually coming out but I would
recommend you check out the comic book
sometime between now and then and if you
do have the DC streaming service they do
post the movies there after the DVD gets
released but you have to wait a little
bit longer after they drop on digital
for that to happen everyone posted
reactions in the comments below
which other Elseworlds story do you want
them to turn into a DC animated movie DC
animation tends to be pretty on point
what will happen is is there's a whole
bunch of Star Wars stuff that I'm
working on this weekend a bunch of
Mandalorian so leave all your requests
in the comments below but I'll try to
get to some Marvel and DC stuff in
between that everyone click here for my
brand new Mandalorian episode 7 video
and click here for the trailer for the
next part of crisis on Infinite Earths
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]